are joined now by dr amish adulja he's a
senior scholar at johns hopkins center
for health security at the bloomberg
school
of public health dr adelga let's start
with the delta variant an estimated 10
percent of cases here in the u.s are
that new variant that's up from 6
percent
the previous week and 99 in the uk
nearly all the cases are this delta
variant
what makes this strain so dangerous
what makes the strain more dangerous is
that it's accumulated several mutations
that allow it to transmit more
efficiently from person to person
so when you're in a situation where
there is a group of unvaccinated
individuals or a county where the
vaccine levels are low and there's not
much natural immunity
this can really take off and spread much
faster than we saw with
the original version of the virus or the
uk alpha variant so this is something
that we need to stay ahead of
to avoid you know things spiraling out
of control in unvaccinated populations i
don't think it's going to be the same as
what we saw in the spring or what we saw
even in the winter
but for an unvaccinated person the
individual risk is very very high
what about those who are vaccinated just
how effective
are the vaccines the moderna the pfizer
the johnson and johnson against
this delta variant this is the the good
thing about our vaccines they are some
of the most highly effective vaccines
that we've ever developed as a species
and when you look at the delta variant
people uh that have had both doses of
the moderna and pfizer vaccines are
basically virtually completely protected
from this this
strain so whatever happens is going to
be something that we can prevent by
getting more vaccines into people
we don't have all the data on the jnj
vaccine but i suspect it is
it is similarly protective against this
variant but we're looking for data more
data for the jnj vaccine
doctor the president set a goal of 70 of
adults american adults to be vaccinated
by july 4th right now as we mentioned
before
we're at 45 with one dose and 53
fully vaccinated what do you believe can
be done to boost those numbers
we have to make it as easy and
convenient and as normal for people to
get vaccinated as possible
unfortunately we're kind of hitting this
wall of vaccine hesitancy where the
people who wanted to be vaccinated
have been vaccinated already and it's a
lot of effort just to get a single dose
into people anymore so i think what we
have to do is make this something you
can get anywhere you don't need to have
an appointment you don't need to put
your social security number or your
insurance information into some website
you should just be able to go and get it
at the subway
on the beach wherever you might be we
also i think need to ask
you know can we get these things fully
approved but they're all approval on
what's called an emergency use
authorization and one of the talking
points
for the people who are kind of spreading
vaccine hesitancy is these aren't fully
approved that these are somehow
experimental which they're not
but i do think the fda giving these full
licensure to the modern
and pfaser vaccines would push doses a
little bit farther as well
okay dr amish adelgia thank you very
much